le bamboo qui est assez sur le sur le
fond avant voici l'astro skin un maillot
muni de plusieurs capteurs pour mesurer
la respiration le rythme cardiaque
la température la pression sanguine et
autres signes vitaux un maillot créé
tout spécialement pour l'astronaute
canadien david saint jacques par la
compagnie montréalaise carré
technologies c'est la première fois
qu'un autre maillot dans l'espace la
première fois qu'il va avoir un
instrument de recherche dans la station
spatiale avant de prendre toute sa
mesure la carre technologies vend depuis
plusieurs années des maillots du même
genre connu sous le nom d' exhaustive
pour les sportifs de haut niveau
athlètes et entraîneurs l'astro skins en
est une version beaucoup plus
sophistiqué tous les quatre sont
intégrés et s'en vont vers un connecteur
sur le côté puis le connecteur
s'intégrer avec une boîte
d'enregistrement
puis le côté astronautes c'est tout ce
qui est à face et le brancher et
connectés et leur entrée dans la poche
et commencer à faire ses autres actifs
et les capacités de strauss kahn david
saint jacques qui s'envole dans un an
pour la station spatiale internationale
n'a pas hésité une seconde
emmener ce maillot dans sa valise et
c'est une grande fierté pour moi d'avoir
la chance d'être le premier canadien à
l'essayer en orbite lors de ma mission
l'astro skins est confectionnée dans un
tissu italien très confortable avec des
propriétés antibactériennes pour évacuer
la sueur
il sera comme une deuxième peau pour
l'astronaute qui devra le porter par
blocs de 48 heures lors de son séjour
dans la station spatiale
les données biométriques enregistrées
dans le petit boîtier seront par la
suite accessibles soit par bluetooth à
une application ipad quels seront vos à
voir avec eux puis une deuxième façon
pas usb quand on a terminé
l'enregistrement on va le brancher sur
un ordinateur spatiale elle prend des
données et les transférer sur terre puis
l' agence spatiale canadienne qui fera
suivre les donner aux chercheurs
associés ses expériences une technologie
qui va donc permettre de mesurer les
effets de l'espace sur le corps humain
mais qui est aussi prometteuse pour la
médecine de l'avenir
je suis sûr que ça va servir ça sur
terre car et technologies espère
d'ailleurs développer prochainement des
partenariats avec des centres de
recherche et des hôpitaux
ici catherine françois radio canada
montréal